well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look then at what
is on the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines with the political
correspondent at the financial times
jasmine cameron shileshi and the
political editor of the scottish son
rachel watson both with us from now
until just before midnight welcome to
both of you as therefore let's check out
the front pages first of all though and
after boris johnson's latest partygate
grilling by mps in the commons the metro
leads with the prime minister's own
words i'm truly sorry
the guardian quotes sakir stama in the
debate labeling mr johnson a man without
shame
the eye leads with the comments by
former party chief whip mark harper that
mr johnson is not worthy of great office
the daily mirror looks ahead to
thursday's vote on whether the pm should
face a parliamentary inquiry listing the
reasons why it thinks he should and
tells tory mps you choose
according to the times though those same
mps have already been ordered to block
any inquiry
well the telegraph reports that germany
has refused to send heavy arms into
ukraine to bolster its defense despite
other western countries doing so
while the daily mail reports that new
rules for self-driving cars will even
allow the driver to watch television and
browse the web
reminder that by scanning the qr code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch
the program so let's bring in then the
political correspondent at the ft
jasmine cameron shileshi and the
political editor of the scottish son
rachel watson welcome to both of you so
another extraordinary day in parliament
um rachel um there's the picture of
boris johnson front page of the daily
telegraph um how did he do as he
prepares to fly to india
i think again as we saw and you
mentioned there this wholehearted
apology that the prime minister gave and
but being very defiant in the fact that
he wants to remain and i think
what we saw in parliament was what we've
heard over the last couple of days from
the prime minister and others around him
around the fact that he has apologized
for this he will continue to apologize
for this
and that line that he
didn't realize and that this was a
breach of the rules at the time and the
rules that he had written and i think
um you know the fact that they're a
little more offered than what was heard
from the
and it was what we've heard over again
and i think one of the biggest takeaways
from it was actually the performance of
so curious armor and i think other
papers have laid on that i'm the
telegraph lead on the fact
that originals will still fight off on
his visit to india you know he is
defiant this is still happening and and
he doesn't want want the party gate
round to get in the way of his job and
going on this trip
cements that and shows that that's what
he's doing um but when you look at some
of the other you know and comments in
the telegraph go into this as well the
fact that so kirsten did really give him
enough time in parliament as did some
others from his own party and the snp as
well and i think that while the prime
minister might have hoped that today
would put it behind him we know that
there's yet more to come later in the
week
um and i don't think this is going to be
anything soon
yes we'll try and tweak your sound it's
not absolutely brilliant rachel but i'm
sure we'll get there um so jasmine to
you and the fact that he is heading to
india does it show some confidence about
the vote on thursday this question of
whether he deliberately misled
parliament whether it should be referred
to a commons committee to investigate
that committee could therefore request
some of the documents that we've not
seen in full etc etc all the parts of
the story that means it doesn't go away
but fundamentally does it mean that
they're actually quite confident that
those tory mps will be voting um with
and for the prime minister
i think it really shows that the
government is keen to show that it's
business as usual and they don't want
partygate to stay in the headlines as
much as it is and they really want to
prove that the government does have
other priorities such as addressing um
the issue of the crisis in ukraine such
as building relationships and
strengthening those relationships with
countries such as india but i do think
rachel raises a good point of this isn't
actually going to go anywhere and
obviously the pm has given an apology
and a statement but this is only in
relation to one fine um that was linked
to his birthday party now that situation
i think a lot of people can always give
them the benefit of the doubt and say
well he says he was only in the room for
nine or ten minutes is it that bad i
think where things start to get a little
bit trickier is when we look at some of
these more contentious events for
example the bring your own wine and beer
event and i think that will be harder
for johnson to justify and that would be
harder to sort of sweep under the carpet
and i think it was quite interesting in
in the chamber in that i think a lot of
tory mps at the moment are just sort of
waiting and seeing how this all plays
out i think there's a sense of not
wanting to criticize the pm too deeply
and that we don't know how local actions
we play out we don't know what will
happen in terms of fines but at the same
time there is a growing discomfort about
how long this is going to stretch out
for and i think the fact that we saw
someone like mark harper who was a
former chief whip sort of putting his
head above the parapet and expressing
his discontent with the pm
it doesn't bode well because this isn't
like for example with coronavirus where
we saw a very clear faction of mps that
were disgruntled with the pm we're
seeing different types of mps from
different wings of the party slowly sort
of voicing their discomfort slowly
putting letters in and that speaks to
the fact that this issue isn't really
going away and it speaks to the fact
that the pm so there's a lot more work
to do to win over those tory mps yes
both the guardian and the inside pages
of the
metro rachel pick up on um what you
brought into which is secure stammer the
guardian a man without shame
and the metro to the pm's latest apology
is just deflections and distortions the
question is will they land a hit will
this make any difference and has boris
johnson been permanently holed under the
water line and and we won't necessarily
know that yet will we
i think one of the biggest problems with
this is when it comes to um whether this
is a resigning matter boris johnson is
forced to go it's actually down to his
conservative mps and that's the biggest
issue here and that's why i think we see
this concerted effort from boris johnson
tonight and speak to back bench mps and
you know telling them to vote against
this labor emotion that's coming later
in the week um a couple of months ago uh
when it first came out and it first
emerged that boris johnson had been at
some of these parties there were a
number of mps who
raised their head above that power pit
and said you know we don't think boris
johnson should be prime minister anymore
we know some letters went into the 1922
committee but we also know some of those
people have taken those letters back out
have publicly supported the prime
minister now and like douglas ross the
scottish conservative leader who's done
complete u-turn on what he believed just
a couple of months ago and because it
seems like there's a number of issues
here and i think
you know when the conservatives are
looking at it we've heard a lot about
how they don't want to replace um boris
johnson when the war in ukraine is going
on or the cost of living crisis and they
do have the local elections coming up we
just don't know what's going to happen
with that but i think also we've never
really seen
a real effort from back bench mps
they've never corralled together there's
never been this movement
yet
and because there doesn't there's not a
clear successor so sometimes when you
when you're looking at this and mps are
looking to replace someone it's because
they have someone else that they can
back i think that's one of the biggest
problems that we see is that actually
who would it be who'd everyone throw
their support behind and it's all really
to do with
what will happen in the local government
elections i think that could be a bit of
a turning point for some mps yes we saw
rishi soon act didn't we uh sitting
alongside him on the front page of the
guardian there he's had a a very
difficult couple of weeks the uh the
successor that was at the times
certainly as you mentioned talks about
how uh torrey mps are being cajoled to
vote a certain way there had been a call
for a free vote come thursday and that
great guessing game that you mentioned
about how many letters the graeme
brady's got we've been playing that for
a long time with the theresa may before
have we not and this question of whether
he's still the heineken politician that
can deliver you know do you do you think
the great test will be those may
elections and the wakefield by-election
coming up um jasmine or you know is it
always going to go badly in the midterms
as politicians like to say
i mean i think that would be the defense
of the conservative policy if it does go
badly they'll say we've been in power
for a long time there's always a little
bit of the turning against the ruling
party but i think the big question that
tory mp's are asking themselves is is
johnson still an election winner if we
look at the polls we can see that labour
heads ever so slightly nationally but
it's not as though this outpouring of
criticism has translated into a soaring
lead for labour so there is a real
so mps are sort of divided because on
one hand some of the tory mps feel as
though well yes the headlines are bad
but they can point to the vaccine role
that they can point to the brexit deal
they feel like they can point to certain
policies and say the government is
acting but on the flip side i think
there is a particularly toxic
combination of these particular
headlines alongside the cost of living
concerns and rising energy bills and
there's a sense that the two of those
combined could really impact stronger
than the pool in the local elections and
so i think a lot of tories are sort of
holding fire and sort of waiting to see
how bad it actually is because i think
as soon as they're convinced that
johnson's no longer the election winner
that they assumed he was i think they'll
turn on him pretty quickly yes there
seems to be a long way to run on this
still doesn't there at jasmine rachel
stay there lots more still to come
including this on the front page of the
daily telegraph which reports that
germany is isolated as the west sends
heavy arms to ukraine
[Music]
well welcome i ain't watching the press
preview with me now the political
correspondent at the financial times
jasmine cameron shileshi and the
political editor of the scottish son
rachel watson welcome back to both of
you
let's turn our attention to ukraine
shall we um certainly the guardian talks
about the battle uh for donbass russians
overrun a city they say uh the first
city to go a criminal city that had more
than eighteen thousand people in it
became under ferocious russian attack
the assault they said took place from
all sides and while the guardian picks
up on the promise of extra help uh the
u.s britain canada france and germany
all offering extra help but um according
to the telegraph jasmine it's it's it's
it's not the heavy arms that ukraine
needs
from germany that is apologies
so the telegraph story is quite
interesting because it sort of picks up
on some of the divisions that are
occurring between western countries so
it notes that germany isn't that keen to
send reinforcements at the moment and it
mentions italy is the same as well and i
think at the very beginning of this
conflict we really saw the western
leaders sort of unify together but it's
only inevitable that at this stage in
the conflict has there's been a round of
sanctions there's been a round of
conversations between all the countries
that we are starting to see those
divisions sort of intensify and i think
it speaks to the fact that western
leaders need to keep having these
conversations we need to keep assessing
actually how can we keep the pressure on
russia how can we sort of
help ukraine in the best way possible
but i think it shows that actually there
still is a lot of work to be done hence
why you know these discussions are
ongoing and why st johnson for example
is very keen to sort of reiterate that
the need to help ukraine
yes there's always been a very fine line
hasn't there that defensive weapons were
offered you know anti-tank missiles for
example anti being the clue to the
defense of nature and and how far you
step over the line certainly helicopters
howitzers were latest on the list from
the americans to be sent there um but
but obviously boris johnson was delayed
in the comments today because he was on
a phone call was he not with world
leaders including joe biden rachel so
what more help do you think britain
might choose to offer in this you know
desperate battle now in eastern ukraine
i think as jasmine points out um from
the stories for tomorrow there are
countries um in the west the uk usa who
are willing to continue providing these
defensive weapons to ukraine and that's
where these lines have been drawn i
guess with that
companies including germany i think the
telegraph piece is really interesting
because it talks about the frustrations
that olaf schultz is facing in his
country um because he thinks that they
have maxed out the
the weapons or the defensive weapons
that they can provide to ukraine and
instead they want to go down the route
of providing a um financial assistance
and i think as jasmine said we will see
more of this we will hear about more
meetings i'm sure with boris johnson joe
biden oliver schultz all the leaders in
the west who need to really have this
unified position on how they will
continue to rachel stand up for russia
apologies for interrupting you we've run
out of time i do apologize rachel watson
jasmine cameron chileshi thank you both
very much indeed we'll see you soon